The genome of human cells is arranged
in 46 chromosomes. So, random sorting
of the DNA would almost certainly lead
to errors. Indeed, many human diseases
are caused by this type of error. To
avoid this problem, cells with nuclei
have evolved a precise chromosome
division process called mitosis.
In preparation for mitosis,
the cell first makes a copy of all of
its DNA.
During the process of DNA replication,
a protein complex called cohesin is
laid down to hold the two resultant
sister chromatids together. Now the
cell enters mitosis.
An important structure called the
mitotic spindle forms. This structure
is made up of many long fibers of
protein, called microtubules,
that attach to chromatids.
Once attached, the spindle pulls on the
chromatids, but the sisters won't
separate because they are held together
by cohesin. In order for mitosis to
proceed, every pair of sister
chromatids must be attached and
pointing towards opposite ends of the
spindle. The cell has a sensing pathway
to wait until this condition is met.
Once the chromosomes are all correctly
attached, a protein that cuts cohesin
is activated. Now that the connection
is cut, microtubules can pull sister
chromatids in opposite directions.
Importantly, this means that each side
of the cell gets exactly one copy of
every chromosome. Now the cell can
divide to create two daughter cells,
each with a precise copy of the genome.